[Music]
Camila thank you so much for sitting
with me thank you so much for having me
I'm so excited to be here of course so I
want to first talk about what exactly
your company does can you explain sonoro
for me yeah so sonoro is a global
entertainment company so we develop
audio first IP so Concepts that start as
podcasts primarily with latino creators
around the world so in English Spanish
or bilingual and then we take that IP
and develop it into TV film books event
series um merchandise e-commerce
basically everything under the Sun so
cool so tell me about your founding
story what were you doing before and
then how did this company come about
yeah so I mean I think it it all really
started as when I was in childhood
honestly I've always been in love with
storytelling that's what brings me the
most passion and the most joy and when I
was little it really started in books
and video games and TV shows that I
loved and so I always knew I wanted to
do something in the entertainment or
storytelling space um right after
college my first job was actually in
non-fiction storytelling so I was at the
LA times for about four years um I was
in this very small sort of R&D unit
within the company that was tasked with
developing new forms of revenue streams
and essentially looking at the
journalism as IP for the company and
figuring out how do we take this beyond
the written word beyond the website and
Beyond the the print paper and so in
that sort of Journey I came across audio
and podcasting as this really great way
to develop IP and make it grow and and
sort of uh enhance the audience that we
already had and so in 2017 I was part of
the team that launched dirty John which
was the first podcast LA Times ever
produced it was this insane True Crime
Story um and it was sort of a runaway
success uh today it has over 80 million
downloads and that was the first time
that I saw audio as an IP property being
used to develop all different types of
media so that show went on to become a
scripted TV series on Bravo an
unscripted documentary on oxygen a book
um it had a written component in the in
the print paper and in the online
magazine so it was already sort of
having all these touch points and to me
that was like a very big sort of aha
moment that as someone that always loves
stories and content this was sort of
like the next Frontier or the next
medium where that experimentation and
excitement was going to come from um and
also because it was so democratized and
still is it's a pretty accessible medium
and so for someone like me I was Latina
born and raised in Miami looking to
bring more Latinos into the broader
entertainment ecosystem it feel felt
like a really great place to do that um
so I spent the next sort of three years
launching about a dozen podcasts with
the LA times and then at that point sort
of felt ready to go and build something
more from the ground up it was a little
bit of mini startup within a larger
organization at the time and and gave me
I think the entrepreneurial itch to to
really get with my co-founders and start
Toral how did you go from like being a
journalist to Storyteller someone who's
behind the scenes to then kind of being
a founder and how did that feel to make
that leap yeah so I mean I was on the
business side so I feel like I was
always a little bit behind the scenes
and really I I was really excited to be
able to work with the the journalists
who were the storytellers at that point
um to develop ideas and to sort of talk
high level creative content strategy but
really to think also about the the
broader purpose and the BR broader
strategy of of that business so I was
always sort of in that behind the scenes
role and so today um in sonoro I'm head
of content so I'm still sort of playing
that role where I'm thinking about what
we're making why we're making making it
and also constantly interfacing with our
creators so our writers directors
producers Etc um and also our partners
that allow us to sort of produce and
launch these properties first in audio
and and then beyond awesome and how did
you meet your co-founders and and what
was that like the how did you decide
okay we're g to make this company and
make it happen yeah it was really
serendipitous honestly I had been
feeling for a while like I said that I
was sort of itching to to start
something new and really was just
introduced to them by a mutual friend of
the industry and and they both come from
sort of complimentary backgrounds to
myself so I was coming from this very
content focused uh role where I was
thinking about IP and thinking about the
growth of that um our CEO my co-founder
came from more traditional media
backgrounds and also had um start up his
own companies and other Industries
before and so had that more uh boots on
the ground experience and our third
co-founder is based in Mexico City so he
had sort of the um the flag posted in
Latin America which was really important
to our growth and our sort of
Distinction as an entertainment company
and so I think when we all met first and
foremost we all got along which I feel
like was very much an instant connection
there for us um we all had complimentary
backgrounds complimentary skill sets we
thought very similarly about um building
teams and and operations and that sort
of thing and I think it it just felt
like it was the right place and the
right time very cool now there's so many
podcast companies out there today
obviously a lot of entertainment
companies as well how do you stand out
from like the Wes of the world or or
other companies doing similar things but
maybe through a different lens yeah I
think for us first and foremost we
really believe ourselves to be an
entertainment company so for us audio is
really just that first step it is um we
want everything to exist beyond that and
like I said it can be TV it can be film
which is more what you've traditionally
seen podcasts become but this month we
launched our first graphic novel which
is based on a podcast that we produced
we have um Live Events and tours with
some of our podcasters that were're
producing as well going into next year
so we're really thinking about it from
like a 360 holistic approach and audio
being just that first step and then
separately of course for us the focus
really is the Latino Community around
the world and the there's 500 million of
us there's 500 million Global Spanish
speakers 60 million us Latinos and so to
us it's a niche that's not a niche
because there it's just so vast and such
a global um Community not just for the
audience but also for the creators that
we're working with so for us that is our
big uh differentiator very cool now talk
to me about some of your favorite um
entertainment podcasts books shows shows
that you've produced what are some of
your biggest hits yeah so I would say a
big sort of uh genre that we're pursuing
is really Reinventing the delaa is a
multi- hundred million uh sort of
industry and property and we felt it was
sort of due for a bit of a refresh and
so we've really doubled down on
developing what we call sort of
modernized NOA so they're taking the
tropes that you see in those series and
keeping them and bringing them to life
because that's what we love we love
knowing you know the evil villain and
the you know waking up from the dead and
all those sort of like crazy Dramatics
that we as Latinos a lot of us grew up
loving it's one of the biggest sort of
through lines across sort of all the
cultures within the Latino Community but
we're also making some twists and
bringing them sort of into the into the
modern world and so our first sort of
modern Tel NOA that we launched was
called Princess of South Beach so it was
36 episodes in English and in Spanish
had Rachel zler as the star who now of
course is on Westside Story and Snow
White and it just sort of hit it out of
the park it was a really funny um
dramedy about two twins separated at
Birth set in Miami and we just announced
earlier this year that it's now in
development at Netflix to become a
series oh wow so that's probably I
personally again I'm from Miami so I had
a little like special place in my heart
for for a story set there um but it did
really well and it got the audience
really excited how do you decide which
Studios and streaming Studios to partner
with and what are you looking for in a
partner I mean I think for us so one
interesting thing of the way we think
about our development of RP is that the
podcasts are really a proof of concept
right and so we are experimenting with
how to develop those from an audio
series into TV show that might have
three four five seasons and so when
we're looking for a partner for the
derivative side they're working with us
on that Vision typically of taking
something that normally has sort of all
the loose ends tied up by the end of a
podcast Series right so normally audio
series are maybe one two seasons and so
we're really working with folks that see
the Creative Vision for this to go on
for potentially years um and that's
really the the main filter for us it's
like the partner that's going to be the
most excited that really gets um the
vision for each individual story that
appreciates sort of the cultural
connection to the Latino Community as
well which sometimes it's very overt
sometimes it's very subtle that to us I
think is the biggest filter amazing so
now I want to talk about your
fundraising Journey can you tell me
about how much you've raised and what
the process has been like for you yeah
so today we've raised about $13 million
so our primary investors are lir hippo
and founder Collective and grcraft we
have some really excellent um media
investors and again I've been very lucky
to have um some great co-founders to go
on that Journey with and I think that in
a way we were familiar and unfamiliar as
a concept right like people understood
at the time we launched March 2020 at
that point there had been audio I know
right that's a fun time to launch a
company interesting timing um but people
understood conceptually to a certain
extent the audio to TV and film Pipeline
and I think where we had to um sort of
do more education in our pitches frankly
was we're going beyond that we really
are thinking about this as a global
entertainment company that's developing
not just uh TV and film but all these
other mediums and focusing on This
Global community so I think there was a
bit of familiarity there which worked to
our our benefit right with sort of that
pipeline that was growing and continues
to grow um but I think it was a a really
great experience of sort of talking
about a community that obviously I am
from and I hold very dear and um the
partners that we have on board today
really sort of get that which is great
that's amazing would you say that there
would ever be a world in which you could
see yourself selling your company and if
so what would it take uh that's a good
question um no absolutely I think that's
that's the ultimate goal for us um and I
think it would just have to be the right
partner I think we still have a lot of
really great shows in our pipeline that
I want to get out into the world but
it'll all be similarly to how we're
thinking about those D individual
derivative partners that sort of see the
Creative Vision understand it and want
to help us take it to that next level I
think that would be sort of a similar
type of relationship that would have to
be built is there one business rule that
you always operate by no matter what um
I don't think it's a business rule but I
think more since I'm really overseeing
the content dayto day for me it's like
good ideas can come from anywhere um I
don't we don't have a very strict uh
development process in the sense of who
can bring ideas to the table or who can
really vouch for something I think
that's important globally from our
perspective of you know making sure that
all of these stories are that are coming
from Latin America are coming from
Latinos in the US and around the world
that aren't typically taking a look at
we're taking a look at those and also
internally like anyone on the team can
bring forth an idea and I think that's
maybe perhaps not a business rule but I
think creatively how we're thinking
about content development important to
me certainly is there any type of pitch
or any qualities that you'd say are like
the best pitches that you get or the
ones that you know are going to take off
yeah it's hard to say I mean I think a
lot of it becomes subjective at the end
of the day but I think I'm I'm first and
foremost looking for a Creator who has
passion for the idea like I really want
to see that excitement and that drive to
bring this world to Life audio is a
tricky medium if you haven't played it
before and ultimately it's where all
this stuff starts and so we really need
that excitement that creativity and that
drive and I think especially when we're
starting an audio um the characters and
the character development and those
character arcs are sort of critical
because primarily obviously you can play
with sound to a certain extent to get
action but it's dialogue it's dialogue
dialogue dialog so it's it's really that
character development and that character
Arc that um I'm excited to take a look
at when I look at a pitch talk to me a
little bit about your audience you know
how many is it how many in the US how
many globally and who are the types of
people that you're you're trying to
reach yeah so today we have over 25
million Global downloads so that is
across uh Mexico and ltin America
primarily Mexico and then us Latino so
we're split about 8020 to Lam and the us
and our audience is Young I mean they're
typically 18 to 35 they're in the bigger
cities um in the US they are where you
would expect them to be for primarily
sort of Latino dominated cities in
California Arizona New York Florida Etc
um but they're young and they're sort of
excited and and they're diverse and um
yeah amazing if you could go back in
time and tell yourself something the day
before you started your company one
piece of advice to yourself what do you
think that would be I don't know I mean
I I think I would probably just tell
myself to trust myself and trust my gut
I think I was 26 when this started which
is really crazy to think about um and I
had really just had that one work role I
mean I had had an incredible amount of
responsibilities in that role previously
to sonoro but this was the first big
sort of uh career undertaking I I was
experiencing so I think uh today I feel
very sort of confident in my role but it
obviously it took a minute to sort of
feel comfortable being in a leadership
position and leading sort of we have
about 60 people in La New York and
Mexico City so it's a sizable team so I
would just say to trust myself and
follow my gut that's great advice I need
to tell myself that sometimes too um
what upcoming projects excite you and is
there any fun things in the pipeline for
2024 that you can share there are a lot
of fun things in the pipeline I would
say there's a I'm a big sci-fi fantasy
nerd like growing up and still today
that is like the primary thing I consume
so we have a Sci-Fi project that I'm
particularly excited about um that we've
been working on for a while this really
great Creator um who's done a couple
stuff with Netflix and he's just super
Visionary sort of young director um I
can't share too much about it but it is
about a young girl who um sort of is
dealing with the grief of losing her
mother in space or so she thinks and
there is an interesting technological
aspect so I'm very excited about that
one again personally just a big fan of
that type of content and I think from
sort of like an audio production piece
it's going to be very cool to do sort of
those space scenes and then come back
down to earth like it'll be a really
exciting immersive experience I think
for people how do you decide like which
medium a a pitch or a story should fall
into I mean I think so for us like I
said mainly the pipeline has to start an
audio that is sort of the business model
that we've taken on and so we're always
looking at pitches through that lens and
I think we can be flexible about audio
and push the boundaries but we
ultimately have to believe that it's a
story you can see with your eyes closed
a little bit right and so you have to
work within the bounds of what's
possible I suppose in sound design but
we have really great Tech on our team we
have this um it's basically like a foam
head that is it's like called binaural
audio and you can sort of record the
actors walking around this head to have
it he if you're uh wearing headphones
you can listen to it as if especially
for our horror series things are
creeping up on you or coming out from
the the corner of the side so we're
really trying to push the limits of
what's possible but ultimately it has to
be something that you can see with your
ears makes sense um and last question
for you what do you want your legacy to
be I mean so I was uh just a little nerd
uh when I was young I was incredibly
nerdy I was uh like I said I like loved
fanfiction and sci-fi and fantasy and
all that stuff and part of the reason
why I focused on storytelling as sort of
the through line of my career and sort
of personal choices and interests is
because I just love the way a great
story makes me feel and I think like a
lot of the community that is built
online around those things is really
special for a lot of people especially
that are outcasts when they're growing
up and so I think I hope that my legacy
with sonoro and Beyond really is either
facilitating or being a part of making
these great shows that make people feel
the same way I feel when I read a really
great book that's amazing well thank you
so much for sharing your story with me
yeah no thank you for having
me
oh